[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون وايهد
واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده دائما
نبدا بالعناوين
قائد فاجنر يفتح النار مجددا على القاده
العسكريين الروس ويدعو الى فتح تحقيق
لتورطهم في جرائم تتعلق بحرب اوكرانيا
دعمه المطلق لحقوق الصرب
البيت الابيض يقول ان انسحاب الجيش
السوداني من مفاوضات الهدنه امر مؤسف
ويدعو الى وقف القتال
وايران تحذر طالبان افغانستان من التصعيد
على الحدود والصراع على موارد المياه وراء
التوترات بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ما قال رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
انه طلب من الادعاء الروسيه التحقيق في
احتمال ضلوع مسؤوليناروس كبار في جريمه
تتعلق بالاعداد للعمليات العسكريه الخاصه
باوكرانيا وفي تنفيذها ويمثل الطلب
بريكوجين اكبر تحدياته العلميه حتى الان
ضد كبار القاده العسكريين للرئيس الردمير
بوتين ووزير الدفاع
قال ان هذه الرسائل لن تنشر لان سلطات
التحقيق ستتعامل معها
التحدي عاليا في مواجهه القاده العسكريين
الروس
قائد فاجنر يطالب احتمال ضلوع مسؤولي دفاع
روس كبار في اي جريمه قبل الحرب في
اوكرانيا او خلالها
طلب بريغو يمثل اكبر تحدياته العلنيه ضد
كبار القاده العسكريين لبوتان ووزير
الدفاع ورئيسه هيئه الاركان
وعلى مدى شهور عاكف طباخ الرئيس على
مهاجمه
متهما اياهما بالخيانه قائده العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لم يرد على
انتقاداته وزاره الدفاع امتنعت عن التعليق
ايضا
[موسيقى]
انتقال جغرافي مفاجئ للحرب الاوكرانيه الى
قلب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو قلبت طاوله على
روسيا لتملا المسيرات سماء العاصمه
وبالرغم من ان الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت اسقاط
تلك المسيرات الا ان الكرملين اقر بان
دفاعاته الجويه في موسكو بحاجه الى
تحسينات لمواجهه التقدم غير المتوقع داخل
الاراضي الروسيه وقال المتحدث باسم
الكريملين
في موسكو كانت تعمل بشكل فعال ولكن كان
لديها مجال للتحسين
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي تبحث عنه من هذه الهجمات في
عمق روسيا تقول ان هذه الهجمات ليست محرجه
فقط لموسكو بل هي تشكل ايضا عمليات تضليل
او تشتيت انتباه للقدر وخلق خلفيه مئاتيه
لهجوم المضاد او سعف الصحيفه ترى ان هذه
الضربات الفعليه والمعنويه والتي تمارس
بها كاف ضغطا على هدفها الاساسي هو الخداع
تمهيدا لما هو قادم استراتيجيه اظهرت
فعاليتها في الصيف الماضي بعد ان روجت
اوكرانيا لهجوم مضاد جنوبا لتتحرك القوات
الروسيه بذلك الاتجاه لكن شنت هجمات خاطفه
على الشمال مخترقه الخطوط الروسيه حول
اذا السؤال ما موقف حلفاء اكياف من
الهجمات الاخيره في قلب موسكو المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كور
بيقال ان بلاده لا تريد تشجيع او تمكين
الهجمات الاوكرانيه داخل روسيا ومرر ذلك
بانها لا تريد تصعيد الحرب واضاف كربيا
نواشنطن تحافظ على مخاوفها بشان الهجمات
على الاراضي الروسيه لكنها في الوقت نفسه
ملتزمه بمساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
نفسها مؤكدا ان بلاده لا تملك معلومات عن
هويه مسؤول عن الهجمات الاخيره على موسكو
اما المانيا فكان موقفها مختلفا حيث قلت
الحكومه الالمانيه انها تعتبر الضاربات
الاوكرانيه داخل الاراضي الروسيه مشروعه
طالما يتم تنفيذها باسلحه محليه كما اشار
المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه الى ان
المانيا ستواصل تزويد كاف بالاسلحه بهدف
الدفاع عن ارضها
[موسيقى]
ملف اخر ايضا يتصدر الاخبار وهو صراع
متجمد بين صربيا وكوسوفو يذوب عنه الجليد
من وقت لاخر مع اي شراره بسيطه توترات
جديده اذا اندلعت هذا الاسبوع بعد مواجهات
بين الشرطه في كوسوفو وقوات حفظ السلام
التابعه للنيتو من جهه وبين صرب كوسوفو من
جهه ثانيه تمديد كالعاده هو الموقف
الاوروبي الثابت من التوترات بين سوريا
وكوسوفو السعيتين للانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في اوروبا ادانا اعمال العنف
التي قد تؤدي لاوضاعا خطيره للغايه منتظرا
تدابير فوريه من الطرفين للنساء الفتيل
لكن الازمه لا تقتصر على حدود البلدين بل
ترمي بثقل تداعياتها على الاتحاد الاوروبي
خبر الاكد ان اوروبا لا تتحمل صراعا اخر
[موسيقى]
لكن ما اسباب التوترات الاخيره بين صربيا
وكوسوفو خلفيه التوترات الحاليه تعود الى
ابريل الماضي بعد ان قطع صرب كوسوفو
والانتخابات المحليه ليسيطر الالبان على
المجالس المحليه الصرب عادوا ليستولوا على
مباني البلديه محتجين على تنصيب رؤساء
البلديات من العرقيه الالبانيه كما
استخدمت شرطه كوسوفو قنابل مسيله للدموع
لردع المحتجين ما ادى لوقوع اشتباكات
بينهم وبين الشرطه وقوات حظ السلام
التابعه للنيتو من جهه ثانيه ما ادى
لاصابه نحو 30 عنصرا من قوات حب السلام
والعشرات من الصرب المحتجين
بؤره جديده قديمه للتوتر في اوروبا مواجهه
بجذور تاريخيه ضاربه في الماضي بين كوسوفو
وصربيا صراع بلغه التاريخ والجغرافيا
الحكايه تعود الى سنوات خلت كوسوفو التي
اعلنت استقلالها عن صربيا عام 2008 تشهد
مواجهات متكرره في شمالها حيث تشجع
بيلغراد الصربع على تحدي السلطات الساعيه
لفرض سيادتها على المنطقه باكملها
كوسوفو دوله معترف بها جزئيا تقع في جنوب
شرقي اوروبا تبلغ مساحتها نحو 11 الف كيلو
متر مربع فيما يبلغ عدد سكانها مليون و
800 الف نسمه من ضمنهم 120 الف صربي اما
اغلبيتهم الساحقه فمن الالبان المنطقه
شهدت احداثا دمويه
البانوكوسوفو تعرضوا لهجمات متتاليه من
قبل الصرب كان اعنفها في العام 19
حينها شنت قوه الناتو هجوما على
يوغوسلافيا استمر 78 يوما لتنتهي الحرب
بعد انسحاب القوات الصربيه ومنذ ذلك الوقت
تعمل قوات تابعه للحلف على حفظ السلام
هناك اصابع الاتهام الغربيه تشير الى
روسيا وتتهمها بدفع الوضع نحو التصعيد من
اجل الضغط على اوروبا الكرملين اعلنها
صراحه وقال ان موسكو تؤيد صربيا وحقوق
صربي كوسوفو بشكل كامل وغير مشروط
التوترات تتزايد يوما بعد يوم وحدتها وصلت
الى اعلان الرئيس الصربي الكسندر وضع جيش
بلاده في حاله تاهب قصوى مع تحرك وحداته
نحو الحدود القريبه مع كوسوفو مشاهد تعيد
الى الاذهان صور النزاع العنيف في المنطقه
قبل اكثر من عقدين من الزمن بلال البجداني
العربيه
تزايد القلق في اوروبا من اندلاع الصراع
جديد يزيد اع التي تفاقمت اثر الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا اصابع الاتهام تتجه
نحو موسكو مشتبهه بضلوعها في زياده
التصعيد في البلقان خاصه ان الكرملين اشهر
دعمه التام
روسيا التي تواجه اسلحه الغرب في اوكرانيا
تبحث عن ضربه لاوروبا في خاصرتها الضعيفه
في البلقان او هذا على الاقل ما تقوله
كوسوفو تقول رئيسه كوسوفو ان الرئيس بوتين
قد يستخدم الوضع في كتفه لتصعيد الصراع في
اوكرانيا وزعزعه استقرار اوروبا بشكل اكبر
المتحدث باسم الكريم
مشروط صربيا والصرب في البلاد واشار
فاسكوبي الى ضروره احترام جميع حقوق
ومصالح سرب كوسوفو وضمانها وفق تعبيره
اننا نراقب الوضع وندعم صربيا والسربه
بشكل مطلق وغير مشروط نعتقد انه يجب
احترام جميع الحقوق والمصالح المشروعه
لسرب كوسوفو وضمانها ولا ينبغي ان يكون
هناك مكان لنوع من الاعمال الاستفزازيه
التي تنتهك حقوق الصرب بالطبع نتابع
التطورات عن كسب وقلقون بشان ذلك
اما الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون فحمل
سلطات كوسوف ومسؤوليات الاضطرابات الاخيره
حيث دعا الى احترام اتفاقي وقف التصعيد
لقد اوضحنا لسلطات كوسوفو انه كان من
الخطا المضي في انتخابات من هذا النوع
سالتقي مع المستشار الالماني
اولربيا كما فعلنا في اجتماع براك لكن من
الواضح جدا ان السلطات الكوسوفيه تتحمل
بعض المسؤوليه عن الوضع الحالي وكان هناك
عدم احترام لاتفاق مهم تم التوقيع عليه
قبل اسبوعين فقط
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان بلاده تشجع
المنافسه مع الصين للمواجهه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لمتابعه ما يجري بين
كوسوفو وصربيا ينضم اليه الان من بيل
جراده دوشان مؤسس ورئيس المجلس التنفيذي
لمنتدى العلاقات العرقيه سيده جنجيتش اهلا
بكم معنا هل فقط الانتخابات البلديه هي
كانت السبب وراء هذا التصعيد ام الطرفان
كانوا بانتظار اي شراره للتصعيد بينهما
سعيد
في عمليه التصيد وعمليه والصراع الامني هو
صراع مفتوح يطالعه حتى المؤسسات
قد لا تتعلق المساله بالعمد الذين تم
تعيينهم في البلديه فقط بل هناك ايضا وجود
مجموعات قد يكون لها ارتباطات بالدوله
خارجيه او مصلحه خارجيه
وهناك اقتراحات تشير بان
تمت
ازمه حقيقيه قد تعيشها البلاد قد تتحول
الى ذات طابع عسكري
مع عشناه ورايناه من عمليه التعرض القوات
حفظ الامن لاصابات هذا سوف يجعل من تلك
الازمه خطره
وقد تكون الانتخابات الماليه المحليه جزء
من المشكله
طب هل نحن امام سيناريو اوكرانيا جديده
بين كوسوفو وصربيا
لكن
المخاطر موجوده مخاطر
مشاركه الجيش المحلي في هذا الصراع قد
تكون موجوده
وتذكروا ان سبب النزاع يعودوا لسنوات خلت
بين
السكان من ذوي الاصول الالبانيه
من جهه اخرى
كافه الجهات الفاعله الدوليه
الجيش الصربي ايضا لا بد له من الحد من
عمليات المخاطر التي قد تدفع
لاندلاع ازمه مفتوحه
شكرا لك دوشان مؤسس ورئيس المجلس التنفيذي
لمنتدى العلاقات العرقيه على المشاركه
معنا في اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
وصف المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي في البيت الابيض جونغكوربي
انسحاب الجيش من مفاوضات الهدنه بالامر
المؤسف واضاف جونبي ان القتال في السودان
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع يجب ان
يتوقف والمساعدات يجب ان تصل للمتضررين
[موسيقى]
فيلا اثناء لم تتوقف المواجهات حيث اندلعت
اشتباكات عنيفه في مدينتي الخرطوم وام
درمان غداه اعلان الجيش تعليق مشاركته في
مفاوضات الهدنه في جده دون الانسحاب منها
وحمل الجيش قوات الدعم السريع المسؤوليه
حيث قال انها لم تلتزم بالهدنه المعلنه
وكانت مراسله العربيه افادت بان الجيش يرى
انه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديد الهدنه
طالما لا تلتزم بها قوات الدعم السريع
لم يتوقف الامر عند الاشتباكات مشاهدينا
حيث وافاد مراسل العربيه باغلاق كبر
الافتحاد من جهه ام درمان فيما رصد تحليق
للطيران الحربي في سماء العاصمه بالتزامن
مع سماع عدوي اطلاق نار متقطع في منطقه
المهندسين
في الاثناء اعلنت سلطه الطيران المدنيه
السودانيه عن تمديد اغلاق المجال الجوي
امام كافه حركه الطيران حتى الخامسه عشر
من يونيو المقبل على ان يستثنى من ذلك
رحله المساعدات الانسانيه ورحلات الاجلاء
بعد الحصول على تصريح من قبل الجهات ذات
الاختصاص
وبعد انباء عن وفاته ظهر القائد الثاني
لقوات الدعم السريع عبد الرحيم دقلو في
فيديو جديد اكد فيه ان قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان المعروف بحماتي بخير
ويقاتل مع قواته في الصفوف الاولى على
الارض
الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في الصفوف
الاماميه مع قواته والانسان
ذو الفعل
البيان للعمل
[موسيقى]
وننتقل الى ملف التصعيد بين ايران وطالبان
افغانستان ففي ايران لا تشهد هذه الحدود
الشرقيه مع افغانستان توترا لم يرقى بعد
لمستوى الصراع لكن المخاوف من التصعيد
تسيطر على الموقف حادث حدودي هكذا وصفت
ايران اتماس بين الدولتين على اثر اطلاق
حرس الحدود الافغاني النار واندلاع
اشتباكات ادت لسقوط ضحايا من جانبه حضر
وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيد حركه
طالبان من التصعيد ودعاها للتوجيه حرس
الحدود لمنع اي تصعيد محتمل بين الطرفين
وعلى الرغم من تبادل الاتهامات والمسؤوليه
حول بدء اطلاق النار الا ان الطرفين تعهد
بالتهدئه لكن حقيقه ما الذي حدث على
الحدود بين البلدين الاسبوع الماضي
الروايه الايرانيه تقول ان قوات افغانيه
في اقليم نيروز باشرت باطلاق النار على
الطرف الايراني وتحديدا على مركز الشرطه
باستخدام اسلحه خفيفه لتؤكد انها اتبعت
البروتوكولات الحدوديه باطلاق انذار لاحقا
ردت طهران باطلاق النار تجاه قوات حرس
الحدود التابعه للطالبات على الجانب الاخر
اختلفت روايه طالبان التي اكدت ان القوات
الايرانيه هي من بدات باطلاق قذائف هاون
على مطار مدينه زرناج حادث الاسبوع الماضي
ادى الى سقوط ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه قتله من
الجانبين واغلاق الحدود بين البلدين وتبعه
حشد عسكري من الطرفين وسط مخاوف من تصعيد
التوتر
بالرغم من ان هناك علاقات دبلوماسيه بين
كابول وطهران الا ان الاخيره لا تعترف
بحكومه طالبان التي وصلت الى السلطه عام
2021 اسباب اندلاع الصراع ليست واضحه بعد
لكن مراقبين ارجعوها الى صراعا على
الموارد المائيه خاصه بعد تصريحات الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي الذي اتهم في وقت
سابق من هذا الشهر حكام طالبان في
افغانستان بتقييد تدفق المياه الى المناطق
الشرقيه لايران منتهكينه اتفاقيه عام 1973
وقبل النزاع الحدودي الاخير دعا وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبداللهيام
حركه طالبان الى الالتزام باطار قانوني
لحل النزاع المياه بين البلدين
الخلاف المائي الافغاني الايراني خلاف
اساسي على نهرها المند يمتد الى عقود حول
حصه ايران المائيه من النهر عام 1973
[موسيقى]
ابرام معاهده بين الطرفين تقضي بمنح ايران
820 مليون متر مكعب من النهر سنويا لكن
طهران تتهم مجارتها باعدام منحها الحصه
المائيه المتفق عليها
وتغييرها مجرى نهرها المند وبناء السدود
عليه ومع سيطره الطالبان على الحكم اتبع
قاده الحركه السياسه نفسها وارجع السبب
الى نقص المياه في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
ومتابعه لهذا الموضوع ينضم الي من كابول
الكاتب الصحفي محب الله شريف ومن طهران
ينضم الى مدير المركز العربي للدراسات
الايرانيه دكتور محمد صالح صدقيان اهلا
بكما معي ضيفي الكريمين سابدا معك من
كابول الكاتب الصحفي محب الله شريف هل
الموضوع هو هذا التصعيد هو فقط بخصوص
المياه ام هناك اسباب اخرى لان البعض هناك
عده روايات هناك من يروي بانه موضوع تهريب
مخدرات هناك من يتحدث عن موضوع المياه
ماذا يجري بالضبط
اولا اقدم لكم تحياتي وكذلك لضيفنا من
طهران
ولمشاهدينا الكرام هذا الموضوع اعني موضوع
التوتر في العلاقات وخاصه على الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه لا تتعلق مباشره فقط
بموضوع المياه هو كذلك يعني
التصعيد في الاجواء الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين وانما هناك اسباب اخرى كذلك لكن
الواقعات او الحوادث التي حدثت على الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه سواء اكانت من قوات
ايرانيه او من القوات الافغانيه لم تكن
مباشره تتعلق بهذا الامر لكن كما تعرفون
ان التصعيد لما بدا في اي جانب من
العلاقات بين الدولتين فالامر يتصاعد
مباشره لو كان هناك تصعيف قليل جدا في
جانب اخر وهذا كان سبب رئيسي وحركه طالبان
او اماره افغانستان الاسلاميه الوزاره
الخارجيه بالاخص طلبت من جميع الاطراف ان
يصلوا الى الحلب
بمباحثات سليمه وعبر الكلام وليس الرجوع
الى الاسلحه والى القوه واستعمال
اذا كان الجانب الايراني ايضا متمسك
بموضوع التفاوض الدكتور محمد هذا التصعيد
بالنسبه للجانب الايراني هل هو متمسك
بالتفاوض هل يعتبر هذا تصعيد محدود ام
الامور ستؤول الى التصعيد
مساء الخير لك ولضيفك وللمشاهدين حسب
البيان الذي صدر اليوم من السفير الايراني
في كابول كاظم القومي ومن
ولايه اهرارات
الجانبين اكد بان الوضع تحت السيطره وليس
هناك اي تصعيد على الحدود بعد الاشتباكات
التي حدثت قبل ثلاثه ايام وبالتالي انا
اعتقد بان ليس من مصلحه الجانبين سواء كان
الايراني او الافغاني ان
يعني تحدث مثل هذه الازمات وهذا التوتر
وبالتالي نحن نعلم لحد الان لم تعترض
بحكومه كابول اي من الدول لا ايران ولا
باكستان ولا دول الاقليميه ولا المجتمع
الدولي وانا اعتقد بانه هناك مشاكل كثيره
في افغانستان سواء كانت مشاكل امنيه مشاكل
سياسيه ومشاكل الا واجتماعيه ايضا
وبالتالي ليس من مصلحه للجانب الافغاني
ولا الجانب الايراني ان تكون مثل هذه
الاشتباكات خصوصا وان قياده حركه الطالبان
والجانب الايراني متفقان على كل الامور
وهناك مباحثات مكثفه جدا وكل المشاكل
العالقه بين الجانبين تحل من خلال الجهود
التي يبذلها بشكل كبير
الايراني في كابول هل من الممكن ان تكون
افغانستان ايضا تساعد الان من اجل الضغط
على ايران للاعتراف بحكومه طالبان
لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر لا من قريب ولا من
بعيد يتعلق بهذا الجانب
ايران تعرف ذلك وافغانستان كذلك وليس من
صالح افغانستان ان يعني ان تستعمل هذه
الورقه كلعبه ورقه اللعبه في هذا الجانب
وانما اظن واعتقد ان العلاقات الجيده
والقريبه مع ايران ومعجم مع جميع دول
الجوار سوف يخدم مستقبل حركه طالبان
كاماره افغانستان الاسلاميه في هذا البلد
وربما يكون الطريق الوحيد والاسرع والانجح
والاقصر للوصول الى الاعتراف الدولي وهذا
الامر ليعني لما يكون هناك صراع مع دوله
وخاصه مع الجوار وهذا الامر يصل الى تصعيد
اكثر سوف يكون لغير صالح حركه طالبان في
افغان دكتور صدقيان سفير ايران السابق في
كابول قال كلام عن افغانستان بان هذا
الاشتباك هو حرب خطيره ويمكن ان يستانف
لاسباب اخرى كما قال بانه
افغانستان او طالبان هي عنصر معاد للامن
في المنطقه هذا كلام هو عن دبلوماسي سابق
ولكن هل تنظر ايران الى افغانستان وطالبان
بهذا الشكل وبهذا التصور
ربما هذا التفسير كانت سابقا موجود عند
الايرانيين بشان حركه الطالبه لكن بعد
السحب الامريكي من افغانستان وسيطره حركه
الطالبان على الوضع السياسي والامني في
افغانستان كان هناك رغبه ايرانيه وهذا
الاجماع الايراني الذي توصلت اليه طهران
بانه يجب ان تكون هناك علاقات جيده مع مع
حركه الطالبان بالشكل الذي تستطيع ايران
ان تساعد حركه الطالبان من اجل انشاء او
تشكيل حكومه
متعدده الاطراف تستطيع ان تكسب اعتراف
المجتمع الدولي بما في ذلك المجتمع
الاقليمي وتحديدا باكستان وايران لان هذين
البلدين المهمين بالنسبه الى افغانستان
وهم يرعون الكثير من اللاجئين الافغان
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان النظره الجديده
للقياده الايرانيه للحكومه الايرانيه
لحركه الطالبان تختلف عن مرحله ما بعد او
ما قبل انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من
الاراضي الافغانيه شكرا لك من طهران مدير
المركز العربي لدراسات الايرانيه دكتور
محمد صالح كما صادقيان كما ايضا اشكر من
كابول الكاتب الصحفي محب الله شريف
[موسيقى]
نصل الان الى اخر فصول التصعيد بين بكين
حيث دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى
الموافقه على مزيد من الاتصالات بعد حادث
طائره مقاتله الاسبوع الماضي لكن قال انه
لغم وجودي منافسه حقيقيه مع الصين
لعدم انحراف هذه المنافسه الى صراع بين
البلدين استمع
اعتقد ان هذا يؤكد سبب اهميه وجود خطوط
اتصال المنتظمه ومفتوحه بما في ذلك بين
وزراء دفاعنا ومن المؤسف ان الاجتماع الذي
سعى اليه الوزير اوستن لم يمضي قدما مع
نظيره الصيني لكن بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن
هذا يؤكد سبب اهميه مشاركتنا المنتظمه عبر
اعلى المستويات كما قلنا مرارا وتكرارا
رغم ان لدينا منافسه حقيقيه مع الصين
فاننا نريد ايضا التاكد من عدم انحرافها
الى صراع وان نقطه الانطلاق الاكثر اهميه
لذلك هي خطوط الاتصال المنتظمه
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
ان الولايات المتحده ملزمه بوقف اعمال
الاستفزاز بارسال السفن الاستطلاع الى
حدود الصين وقالت المتحدثه الرسميه باسم
الوزاره ماونينج نواشنطن تقوم منذ فتره
بعيده بارسال سفن وطائرات لاجراء
استطلاعات قرب الصين ما يهدد سياده الصين
الوطنيه وانها الخارجيه الصينيه اكدت ان
الصين ستواصل اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لحمايه سيادتها وامنها بحزم
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل اتفاق
رفع سقف الدين الامريكي امام مفترق طرق في
مجلس النواب
[موسيقى]
خطوه اخرى امام اتفاق رفع سقف الدين في
الولايات المتحده نحو اقراره الاتفاق الذي
تم التوصل اليه اثر مفاوضات مرهتونيه
سيصوت عليه اليوم النواب الامريكيون لكن
التصويت يبدو صعبا الاتفاق المبرم بين
الرئيس الديمقراطي جو بايدن والرئيس مجلس
النواب الجمهوري
ينبغي ان ينال موافقه نواب الكونجرس في
الوقت الذي ابدى بعضهم وعرض صريحه له كسب
الكونجرس بضعه ايام حيث ان خزينه البلاد
لن تفرغ الا في الخامس من يونيو المقبل
فبحلول هذا الوقت ستواجه واشنطن خطر
التخلف عن سداد ديونها وهو امر غير مسبوق
قد تكون تداعياته كارثيه على الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
رغم ان لجنه القوانين في مجلس النواب اعطت
اول اشاره للاتجاه المقبل عبر المصادقه
على مشروع القانون الا ان الخلافات لا
تزال قائمه حيث يرى الجمهوريون الذين
يسيطرون على مجلس النواب ان مكارتي قدم
الكثير من التنازلات لبايدن من اجل التوصل
لهذا الاتفاق تقول النائب الجمهوريه عن
كارولاينا الجنوبيه نانسيميس انها لن تصوت
لصالح هذا الحل اما مؤيد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في الحزب تعتبروا ان الاتفاق
سيء النائب عن قال انه سيواصلون الكفاح ضد
تمرير القانون مهما حدث الوضع لم يختلف
حقيقه كثيرا بالنسبه الديمقراطيين حيث
اظهر بعض النواب شكوكا مثل روكانا النائب
عن كاليفورنيا الذي اعتبر ان الكثير من
ممثلي حزبه المعارضين لاقتطاعات الميزانيه
لا يعرفون بعد كيف سيصوتون لكن ما ابرز ما
ينص عليه هذا الاتفاق المثير للجدل يتضمن
الاتفاق سقف الدين العام للولايات المتحده
لمده سنتين اي حتى ما بعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 20 24 فيما لم يتضمن الاتفاق
التخفيضات الكبيره التي يريدها الجمهوريون
رغم ان الانفاق غير الدفاعي سيظل تقريبا
من دون تغيير السنه المقبله وسيزيد واسميا
فقط في العام 20 25 كذلك ينص على خفض عشره
مليارات دولار من الاموال المخصصه للخدمات
الضريبيه لتحديث وتعزيز الضوابط وهو ما
كان مطلبا للجمهوريين وكذلك استرداد
الاموال المخصصه لمكافحه كوفي 19 والتي لم
تنفق بعد
من واشنطن ينضم الى مراسله عربيه حسين
التوضي حسين اهلا بك معنا هل الاجواء
الايجابيه ما زالت مسيطره حول التصويت على
تمرير هذا القانون
تحيه لك يا ميسون بالفعل هذا من الحظه
وقبل قليل كان هناك تصويت على قاعده
لاحضار هذا المشروع الى
ارضيه مجلس النواب لتصويت عليه فيما بعد
اسعار الساعه الثامنه والنصف بتوقيت
واشنطن وقد
نجحت او نجح المشرعون بالتصويت عليه
بمساعده الديمقراطيين الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
صوتت مع هذه القاعده وسندها بذلك حوالي 29
او 30
ديمقراطيه اذا هناك اجواء ايجابيه هذا
التصويت يعكس ما قد يكون عليه الحال عند
الساعه الثامنه والنصف حتى كيف المقال في
عندما سئل قال انه متاكد انه سيمر هذا
المشروع وعندما سئل عن اذا كان قلقا بسبب
البعض الذي الجمهوريين الذين دعوا الى
الاطاحه به لم يجيب وقال بالعكس كان يبدو
انه مرتاحا لما يجري وهذا اثار الكثير من
الاسئله حول
قدرته على ضبط المسائل ويبدو ان الرجل
بالفعل واثق من تمريره خاصه في ظل دعم
باقي قاده الكونجرس
وهو زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ قال
انه يامل اذا مر التشريع اليوم في مجلس
النواب ان يتم التصويت عليه في مجلس
الشيوخ ليل الخميس او الجمعه يعني قبل حتى
عطله نهايه الاسبوع اذا هناك دفع القاده
في الكونجرس بمجلسيه يدفعونه ويحاولون حشد
التاييد من قبل
المشرعين للتصويت عليه في المجلسين على كل
حال دائما سنكون معك حسين لتطلعنا على اخر
التحديثات لهذا التصويت الذي سيستمر يعني
حتى ساعات دائما معك حسين التوض مراسل
العربيه كنت بعمل واشنطن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اما سباق الانتخابات الامريكيه فقد حذرت
فوكس نيوز من حمله اعلاميه ممنهجه قالت
انها تهدف لعرقله المرشح واظهاره على انه
خطر على الحريه الفكريه والاكاديميه في
الولايات المتحده حيث وصفت صحف مقربه من
الديمقراطيين الديمقراطيين حاكمه فلوريدا
بالمتشدد
يبدو ان الصعود الصاروخي لشعبيه روندي
سانتوس منافسه ترامب على قياده الحزب
الجمهوري قد اربكت الديمقراطيين مثل ما
اربكت ترامب
فوكس تحذر من حمله اعلاميه مسبقه تشنها
وسائل اعلام تحاول عرقله ديسانتوس باشاعه
انه اكثر خطرا على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
من منافس هترام مستدله بعدد من المقابلات
والتغريدات التي برزت مؤخرا من صحفيين
ديمقراطيين بعد سيزون
صحف مقربه من الجمهوريين تصف ديسانتوس
بانه مستقبل الحزب الشاب الاكثر نجاحا
وشعبيه في البلاد وخير وريث للترامبيه
القويه فيما يحذر ديمقراطيون بان افكار
ديسانس المتشدده تهدد الحريه الفكريه
والاك
وتنمي قوه التطرف ما قد يدفع البلاد لحرب
اهليه
عوده امريكا العظمى تبدا باعاده الى قبو
منزله بلدنا يسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ لقد
انهارت حدودنا الجنوبيه ملايين المهاجرين
غير الشرعيين والمجرمين على قوائم الارهاب
يدخلون الاف الضحايا من المخدرات وانظروا
الى الاقتصاد اداره بايدن تفعل كل ما في
وسعها لجعل الحياه اكثر صعوبه للاسر
العاديه
وديسانتوس سبق وان تحدث عن ميله لاتخاذ
تشريعات صارمه ضد عدد من القضايا التي
يعتبرها الديمقراطيون حريه مثل قضايا
الضرائب والاجهاض والمهاجرين والتعليم
وحمل السلاح
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس البرلمان تونسي ابراهيم بودربالا
في حوار مع العربي انتهاء مرحله الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه في تونس قائلا ان الدعاء
المعارضه بان التشريع لا يزال في يد
الرئيس قيس سعيد مخالطه
احنا تسلمنا المهام يوم 13 مارس الفرد
وشارعنا في عداد النظام الداخلي ثم تركيز
هياكل المجلس من مكتب مجلس واللجان والان
شرعنا في دراسه القوانين وبالتالي يعني
يعتبر تركيز الهياكل في وقت قياسي وبدايه
من هذا الاسبوع سوف نشرع حنا عده قوانين
على اللجان ذات العلاقه وسوف يجتمع المجلس
في جلسه هذا الاسبوع لدراسه احد احد
المشاريع القوانين حضر تقريرنا لمجالات
البريطانيه من تبعات التشريعات التي
اقرتها دولا حول العالم تحت ذريعه الحمايه
المستخدمين من المحتوى الضار والمعلومات
المضلله على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
شرطه الانترنت قادمه تحذير تصدر عناوين
مجله البريطانيه التي نشرت تقريرا نبه الى
تبعات التشريعات التي اقرتها دول حول
العالم تحت زريعه حمايه المستخدمين من
المحتوى الضار والمعلومات المضلله على
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي المجله قالت ان
المجالس التشريعيه لولايات امريكيه
ومحاكمها ترسم خطوطا جديده حول حدود
التعبير حيث يتفق الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون على ضروره تغيير قواعد مراجعه
المحتوى على الشبكات الاجتماعيه لكنهم
يختلفون بشان ما يجب فعله حيال ذلك اما في
اوروبا فذهبت الهيئات التشريعيه الى ابعد
من ذلك اذ سيبدا العمل بقانون الخدمات
الرقميه للاتحاد الاوروبي دي اس اي الذي
تم اقراره في يوليو عام 2022
العام المقبل في بريطانيا من المتوقع ان
يتم سن قانون السلام على الانترنت الذي
تمت صياغته بعد انتحار مراهق يبلغ 14 عاما
بعد ان شاهد مواد على الانترنت وتشير
المجله الى ان البرازيل اقرت قانون
الاخبار الكاذبه الذي يعاقب الشبكات
الاجتماعيه لفشلها في تحديد المعلومات
المضلله كما ستعلن الهند عن مشروع قانون
تنظيم الانترنت في يونيو الذي يقال انه
سيحمل المنصات الاجتماعيه مسؤوليه محتوى
المستخدمين
المثير للقلق ان هذه التحركات تلهم
الحكومات في الاجزاء الاقل ديمقراطيه من
العالم لصياغه قواعد جديده خاصه بها
اشارت تقديرات الى ان الزعيم الكوريه
الشمالي كيم جون جوني يعاني من اضطرابات
في النوم ومن سمنه مفرطه وذلك بحسب ما
نقله نواب في البرلمان عن وكاله
الاستخبارات الكوريه الجنوبيه
استخبارات كوريا الجنوبيه تكشف معلومات
جديده عن صحه زعيم كوريا الشماليه
سمنه زائده وارق
140 كلغ وزن زعيم كوريا الشماليه وهو
يعاني من اضطرابات في النوم
الكحول والنيكوتين تسبب بالارق للزعيم
كشفه سواد الجفون تحت عينيه
استخبارات كوريا الجنوبيه كشفت ظهور خدوش
وكدمات باستمرار على يدي وذراعيك يشير الى
التهاب الجلد كدليل على الاجهاد
استخبارات الصول اعتمدت على الذكاء
الاصطناعي للكشف عن الوضع الصحي لزعيم
كوريا الشماليه
بمجرد تحليل صوره الاخيره
ختاما نذكر بابرز ما جاء في اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
قائد فادنير يفتح النار مجددا على القاده
العسكريين الروس ويدعو الى فتح تحقيق
لتورطهم في جرائم تتعلق بحرب اوكرانيا
الناتو يواجه مئات المتظاهرين الصرف في
كوسوفو والكرملين دعمه المطلق لحقوق السرب
البيت الابيض يقول انسحاب الجيش السوداني
من مفاوضات الهدنه امر مؤسف ويدعو الى وقف
القتال
وايران تحذر طالبان افغانستان من التصعيد
على الحدود والصراع على موارد المياه وراء
التوترات بين البلدين
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه دائما لمتابعه
ملفات العربيه العربيه دوت نت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات